- You're very private with
like your personal life.
- Yes.
- And you're pretty open, right?
- I'm way too open and my
husband is way too open.
I'm like, we're not gonna talk
about everything next time
because...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- What has been shown
is our entire sex life.
- That's what you say.
- Oh, great.
- Hey, but that's not a problem.
Congratulations.
(audience clapping)
- That's hysterical.
No one has ever said that.
- Yeah, well, not everybody's
having that life right now.
(audience laughing)
So you're, back to you.
So, you're very private
about it though, right?
You're like.
- So here's the thing, I'm not private.
I have never been private
of my relationship.
I love to flaunt my mans, I love it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause I usually get
them hot, smart, and rich.
- Oh yeah.
All right.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love it.
Yeah.
- You know, women wear jewelry
and we usually have, you
are what you're extended
of the person next to you, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is why I tell guys, I'm like,
I don't know why they're so
afraid of getting married.
You are literally getting
a buildin concierge.
Your wife is like 24 hours concierge.
- No opposite.
- No?
- He's my concierge.
- Well, for you in your relationship,
but most women, they're
the one who taking care
of their wife, what to wear, what to eat.
Married men have a better life.
- That's why some of us
are divorced, but yes.
- Than single men.
- No, I'm with you. (laughs)